- This episode of Wheel of Science
is brought to you by Wix.
- On this episode of Wheel of Science
we're talking politics in space
or Space Force, but you
gotta say it differently.
- Yeah, in space there
are only deep voices.
Space Force.
- This is Wheel of Science.
- Hey everybody, what's up,
and welcome to Wheel of Science.
I'm your host Chuck Nice,
and this is the show where
we answer your questions
about the universe.
Actually, I don't answer
your questions about
the universe, but that would be silly.
The one, the only Doctor
Neil deGrasse Tyson
answers your questions about the universe.
- Hey Chuck.
- What's up Neil?
- Doing good. You found
me in my office today.
- I think this is the longest time that
you have been home.
- Yeah. Sometimes, I gotta
give the universe a rest.
- I disagree with that.
I think the universe can handle you, Neil.
(laughs)
So Neil, before we get to the questions,
why don't you just tell us,
what is Space Force.
- Yeah if that comes to past,
it would just be a
reorganization of the military
with a lot of the activities that
have already been happening
under the auspices of the Air Force.
Many people, I don't think knew,
the Air Force has a U.S.
Space Command within it.
And they're the ones that
conceived and launched
the GPS satellites.
They, with NSA and others,
have spy satellites in orbit.
This been going on since the 60's.
Spy satellites.
So, this concept that
the military use of space
is something new, no it's something old.
And all this would do would
codify it into a new branch
of the Armed Forces.
- So it really already exists.
It's like calling an
apple pie an apple crisp.
- Taking apple pie and hitting
it with a hammer a few times
and call it apple crisp?
(laughing)
- That's exactly what I meant.
Neil, what time is it my friend?
- It is time to spend the wheel.
- My, how formal.
(playful electronic music)
- Mike Maas wants to know
"If, and, when we colonize
another planet, who has
political rights over that body?"
- Welcome to the wild
frontier of space law.
It's not clear.
The Outer Space Treaty stipulates that
you can own anything in space,
so nations cannot declare it there own.
So, if that holds up the answer is
nobody has jurisdiction,
but I think laws imagined many decades ago
may need to be updated and modified given
what we learn and know about the future of
space exploration.
So, we're in need of some
enlightened attorneys
to think this through going forward.
- Oh God, more lawyers.
- No, better lawyers.
- So you mentioned space treaty.
What is that?
- The Outer Space Treaty
was a U.N. document
drafted in the late 1960s,
ratified by, today,
more than 100 countries,
and it's a guideline for the
peaceful use of outer space,
and it's very kumbaya,
you know if your astronaut is in trouble
I come help you and I bring
you food and water and
it's very beautiful, it's
very future thinking,
but it leaves open the
possibility that you
might want to defend your assets in space,
with some form of weapon or another.
Suppose you see a
satellite coming toward you
and you think its gonna hurt you.
Can you preemptively take it out so that
you don't get hurt.
This is the fuzzy area in that document,
but that doesn't subtract
from the fact that
it really is imagining a
future, a very peaceful future,
of cooperation in space,
which I think in the end is a good idea.
- Look at that, Gene
Roddenberry couldn't have done
a better job himself.
- Yep!
- All right, Neil.
You ready for another one?
- Spin the wheel.
(playful electronic music)
- Jenn Shifferd wants to know this.
"Don't we already use
satellites for military action?
What other ways will
they militarize space?"
- Yeah when people think of
the militarization of space
they're often thinking of
Star Wars, weapons, missiles
and things.
Problem is when you're
in space and in orbit
you're going 18,000 miles
an hour in low earth orbit.
If you start busting stuff up,
now you have particles and bits and pieces
of formerly operating satellites,
that are themselves projectiles,
moving at 18,000 miles per hour.
And so, you make a mess of things.
So space war would last
a few hours and then
you'd never have another space war again.
(laughing)
So, space has been the
repository of spy satellites
ever since we've had satellites.
And in that sense, it
has been militarized.
If fact, the Gulf War of
2003 was completely enabled
by space assets, with GPS
satellites leading the way.
Which we think of as just helping you get
to grandma's house in your
car, but it was conceived,
launched and operated by the military,
and was later co-opted
by business interests.
So it'll find grandma's house, Uber,
their entire business model depends on it,
and if you wanna find
a mate within 1.5 miles
of your location, swipe right.
- Interplanetary hook ups.
I like the way you think, Neil.
(playful music)
You've heard me say it a million times,
Wix is the best place
to create your personal
or professional website.
I made wheelofscience.com on Wix.
I found the perfect template,
uploaded our content and hit publish.
It doesn't take an astrophysicist.
That's why Neil didn't do it and I did.
No offense, Neil.
Upgrade to a premium plan and you can get
your own website domain name right away.
Go to wix.com/go/StarTalk and begin--
- All right, you ready for another one?
- Spin it.
(playful electronic music)
- Jade Tollis asked "What
possible injuries or diseases
will combat doctors in the
Space Force find themselves
regularly treating?"
- That's a great question.
Well that depends on how much
we invoke soldiers in space,
as opposed to remote
controlled satellites in space.
You start putting people in space,
and then they start fighting one another,
you might ask well why would you do that,
just put a drone satellite in space.
But if you put people in space,
then there's the long term
effects of zero-g, the bone density loss,
all the same things we
currently know about
from astronauts and
their long term visits to
the International Space Station.
So that's the kind of, I
wouldn't call them injuries,
but they're workplace
hazards I would call them.
Workplace conditions
that are not always in
the interest of your
health or your longevity.
You also have exposure to
higher levels of radiation
from the sun so you wanna
be protected against that,
but if a missile hits you
and you're blown to bits,
same medical needs you
might have if that happened
on earth.
- Hmmm, the difference is when
you scream medic in space,
no one can hear you.
- Yes, Chuck (laughs) that is true.
Not only in space can
no one hear you scream,
no one can hear you explode either.
- Man bro, you went dark.
- Just saying. Let's get real here.
(laughing)
- All right. It's caption time.
We took a picture of Neil and we put it up
and of course we took
captions from our viewers.
And the winning caption is...
Peter Grell "I can
count to two in my head,
but starting at three I
gotta use my fingers."
(laughs)
- That's my favorite
one too, I must agree.
(laughing)
In fact, it goes a little deeper with me
because one of my most
influential books growing up,
beginning in middle school,
was a book called One
Two Three...Infinity,
written by the physicists George Gamow.
And he reference a tribe,
a primitive tribe where
they don't have numbers
for anything bigger than three.
They just can count up
to three then after that
it's just very many.
And so the question was how do they think
about large numbers
relative to small numbers.
So I like that.
It's a throwback to a
time when we really didn't
have to count more that
three things in our lives.
- I just love that while you were reading
One Two Three...Infinity, I was reading
One Fish, Two Fish, Red Fish, Blue Fish.
And that was in high school.
Time now for this weeks poll,
which is "Do you think we
should have a Space Force?"
Answer right here on this page.
All right Neil, what do you think, huh?
- You know, if we have a Space
Force, then the Air Force
motto, Aim High, you lose
to Space Force on that one,
cause their aiming higher,
so I don't know how
you're gonna resolve that one, but--
- So the Air Force would
have to change their motto to
'Lower your expectations'.
- And then the Space Force gets
'The Sky is not the Limit.'
Which happened to be
the title of my memoir.
- You know what I like
most about that answer
is the gangsta way you
slipped in your book plug.
(laughing)
Look at that, we're out of time.
And of course, we have to
say thank you to our very own
personal astrophysicist
Doctor Neil deGrasse Tyson.
(laughing)
Thank you, Neil.
Thank you again, Neil.
- Till next time Chuck.
- Total design freedom.
That's what you get when
you make a website using
the Wix editor.
You want motion background?
Well you got it.
You want an online store?
Well that's a Wix feature.
Animated page transition?
You guessed it. You can go on Wix.
Yeah I like this, lets do it.
You can either use Wix ADI to let
an artificial design intelligence
build your site for you,
or you can use their wide
variety of templates to get
exactly the site that you had in mind.
Upgrade to a custom
domain, like we have at
wheelofscience.com, and let
the world know about your site.
So what are you waiting for?
Go to wix.com/go/StarTalk
and begin your site now.
Believe me. If I can do it, you can do it.
No way I'm as smart as you.
That's our show.
We'll see you next time.
I'm Chuck Nice.
Thanks for watching Wheel of Science.
(playful music)